[Music]
on this Tuesday night winter Wallop
millions of Canadians in the path of a
brutal blast of weather we've already
got our flight delayed the warnings of
what's on the way Donald Trump's legal
fight I think it's very unfair why he
believes he should have sweeping
immunity from prosecution breaking news
Ecuador state of
emergency as a gang leader vanishes from
his prison cell armed groups take police
officers and journalists hostage and
springing into action it's just amazing
to me that they did this the Canadian
teenagers who saved a couple from
drowning global national with Don of
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us the new year is starting with
a punch of winter weather storm warnings
are in effect for large parts of Ontario
Quebec and the maritimes some areas are
bracing for up to 20 cm of snow along
with ice pellets and freezing
rain Canada's capital is caught in it
blowing snow making driving conditions
in Ottawa tricky and causing flight
delays and cancellations there at
Toronto's Pearson airport maintenance
Crews were hard at work clearing the
tarmac this morning as wet snow fell
across the region that snow later turned
to slush making for a messy evening
commute Global News meteorologist
Anthony Farnell is watching it all for
us Anthony it's pretty wet there right
now but give us the big picture Donna
wintry for much of Canada but here in
Southern Ontario it continues to be a
battle between winter and whatever this
is the rain pouring down on me
everything that fell this morning has
turned into slush and that is
problematic on the roads across the
region for the evening commute uh the
snow remains rather heavy as you go
north and east the Ottawa Valley into
Southern Quebec 15 to 30 cm expect Ed
along with the risk of freezing rain
this entire system is headed towards the
maritimes where it's not just snow and
rain but also wind that is going to
cause some problems including power
outages gusts on Wednesday could top 100
kilm per hour now this system doesn't
have much cold air on the backside so
it's not going to be a flash freeze but
there will be more cold available for
the next one in BC big waves Mountain
snow that low will intensify as it moves
down to Texas and takes a very similar
track up the East Coast so it may be a
Repeat Performance for areas from the
Great Lakes through Eastern Canada
Friday into the upcoming weekend very
active weather and very cold air behind
that system Donna okay Global News
meteorologist Anthony farell thanks and
this is what that weather is doing in
western Canada right
now wind warnings are in effect for
parts of coastal BC BC's interior is
getting slammed with heavy snow creating
treacherous driving conditions Alberta
and Saskatchewan are also bracing for
heavy snow and parts of Northern Alberta
could dip to minus 40° with the
windchill in the US hundreds of
thousands of people are without power as
an intense storm moves across the
Central and Eastern parts of that
country heavy snow and blizzard
conditions have caused travel chaos in
parts of the Midwest and Northeast
according to the flight tracking website
Flight Aware more than 1,700 flights
have been canceled in the south east
high winds and heavy rain have caused
severe damage and at least two people
have been reported
killed lawyers for former US president
Donald Trump are arguing he should be
immune from prosecution for his coup
attempt in 2020 when he tried to
overturn the results of the election a
panel of federal appeals judges will
decide if the criminal charges against
him should be thrown out
at one point today a judge asked Trump's
lawyer this hypothetical
question could a president who ordered
Seal Team 6 to assassinate a political
rival who was not
impeached would he be subject to
criminal
prosecution if he were impeached and
convicted first and so so your answer is
is my answer is qualified yes Trump is
facing four criminal counts related to
his effort to remain in office after he
lost Jackson prco explains why this case
is so
important he didn't need to appear in
court Donald Trump came to Washington
anyway to watch his legal team argue he
should be immune from prosecution for
his attempts to overturn the 2020
election a president has to have
immunity and the other thing is I did
nothing wrong before a panel of three
judges Trump's lawyers argued he can
only be prosecuted for official acts if
he's first impeached and convicted by
Congress to authorize the prosecution of
a president for his official act would
open a Pandora's box from which this
nation may never recover the justice
department warned giving Trump absolute
immunity would open the door to abuse of
power by Future presidents never in our
nation's history until this case has a
president claimed that immunity from
Criminal prosecution extends Beyond his
time office more importantly the doj
argued election interference was not
part of Trump's job as president
committing fraud trying to overturn a
legitimate election or even campaigning
courts have historically held that that
is outside the scope of one's official
duties the immunity question is at the
heart of whether special Council Jack
Smith's case against Trump can proceed
for now the trial is on hold an expected
appeal to the Supreme Court could delay
it further I think everyone sort of has
this strong desire to move past this and
to get these allegations resolved so I
don't think it's a sure thing that the
Supreme Court actually takes the case
even after the DC circuit rules Trump
has already been indicted by a grand
jury on four counts of conspiracy and
obstruction this is the first of several
Court appearances for Trump that run
right up against the 2024 presidential
campaign calendar but Trump has shown he
has no problem using his legal wos as
campaign events you think anybody else
could get up here and speak to you all
day and and get indicted four times for
Trump return to the presidency may be
his last best hope for escaping his
troubles with the law Jackson prco
Global News Washington we are watching
events in Ecuador tonight where an armed
conflict is underway after a powerful
gang leader disappeared from his prison
cell and other inmates escaped tonight
hooded armed men stormed a TV studio
during a live
broadcast the men waved guns and what
appeared to be explosives before the
live feed caught out it is one of a
series of what seems to be coordinated
attacks across the South American
country including the kidnapping of at
least seven police officers Ecuador is
now under a state of
emergency Ecuador's president has
ordered the Armed Forces to neutralize
two dozen gangs which he's described as
terrorist organizations and has deployed
more than 3,000 police and Military
Officers US Secretary of State Anthony
blankin is back in Israel repeating his
message that the toll on civilians in
Gaza is far too high and that more food
water and Medicine needs to get into
Gaza so far us pressure pressure on
Israel to ease up its Siege has not
changed things on the ground linkoln
also called for a clear pathway to a
Palestinian State something Israel's
neighbors support but prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu does not Crystal
ganing
Reports as the intense Israeli campaign
aimed at preventing ing another October
7th style attack continues America's top
Diplomat says Israel's security is tied
to security for Palestinians as I told
the Prime Minister every partner that I
met on this trip said that they're ready
to support a lasting solution that ends
the long running cycle of violence and
ensures Israel's
security but they underscored that this
can only come through a regional
approach that includes a pathway to a
pal indan State nice to see you Anthony
blinkin who met with several key Israeli
leaders as a part of a regional tour
announced a un team would be granted
access to the north of Gaza to assess
when and how civilians can return home
while that work isn't expected to happen
soon Israel's foreign Ministry is
dismissing plans suggested by some
lawmakers to resettle displaced Gins to
African
nations
those who fled to the South still live
under constant threat the UN says 80% of
gaza's population has been displaced and
more than 90% face acute food insecurity
a reality understood by even the
youngest in
Gaza the situation is very tragic says
this 8-year-old we are asking all states
to send eight open the Rafa border
crossing to get all the eight in to end
the
war blinc also called for the war to end
as soon as possible but 95 days into
this conflict attacks between the IDF
and Hezbollah have reignited fears the
war could expand to
Lebanon Crystal ganing Global News
London here at home special immigration
measures kicked in today allowing
Canadians to apply for temporary safe
hav for family members trapped in Gaza
the federal government calls it a
humanitarian pathway for those looking
to flee Gaza is hadidi petrac reports
applying is not easy and there is no
guarantee of
success the weight is excruciating and
we're just on hold Lena sakala got up at
midnight to see if the application
process to get extended family members
out of Gaza had opened up at noon still
nothing I'm very mad because it took
Canada so long for them to open up such
a program Ottawa announced the temporary
special immigration measures December
21st the sakalas hope it will help them
bring 10 loved ones to Canada for up to
3 years including a Sak kala's sister
who once slept here before bombing
forced her into a tent the seala say
roughly a 100 relatives have already
been killed in the humanitarian crisis
they are just in one place and suddenly
they have a rocket in the home
and all of them die
the government plan caps applications at
1,000 in a country with an estimated
45,000 Palestinian Canadians consider
the fact that most of them have Lov ones
stuck in Gaza and immigration lawyers
say the complex application process
places a heavy burden on those bringing
relatives in they have to provide a
notorized statement confirming that they
will financially support their loved
ones from Gaza for a period of at least
one year limits and condition marus says
didn't exist for others fleeing conflict
from Ukraine or Afghanistan can I from
this from this computer no this by
mid-afternoon the online application
portal went live and the scramble began
if they get in under the cap the
application has to be approved and even
then Ottawa says there is no guarantee
clearing that hurdle will mean clearing
the Rafa border I just have to sit and
watch my loved ones being killed by
bombing or starvation or diseases with
no timeline yet on when families could
be reunited Heidi pic Global News
Halifax Police in Quebec are
investigating an attack inside a
courthouse in longay South Montreal a
68-year-old man was attacked with a
sharp weapon this afternoon he's in
hospital in serious condition a
43-year-old man has been arrested and
could face attempted murder charges
police say the victim and the suspect do
not know each other the Quebec
government has announced a $300 million
plan to help students catch up after a
teacher
strike hundreds of thousands of students
return today after more than a month out
of class schools will be able to use the
provincial money to organize tutoring
for students and the help will be
volunter and offered outside of regular
school hours people in BC will soon be
the first in Canada to have access to a
self-screening test for cervical cancer
hoping it will detect cancer sooner at
home test kits will be available to
order online or over the phone and will
screen for HPV the leading cause of
cervical cancer The Province says the
test is quick easy and more accurate
than Pap tests the traditional method of
testing Houston we have a problem coming
up why NASA is delaying two missions to
the
moon coming up on 60 seconds into the
flight everything looking good well it
went from looking good to looking like
impossible for the first US moon lunar
lander in over half a century paragr 1
developed a critical fuel leak hours
after liftoff yesterday astrobotic the
private company behind the project now
says there is no chance of a soft
landing on the moon and says the
spacecraft will run out of propellant in
less than 40 hours the Lander is
carrying NASA scientific equipment along
with human remains of former presidents
and space enthusiasts NASA is working
with astrobotic to identify the root
cause of the the propulsion issue and
says space is hard space is also
dangerous and today NASA announced its
planned missions to the moon will be
delayed because of safety and technical
issues McKenzie gray explains what's
happened and what's
next this was the walk Canadian Jeremy
Hansen and three other astronauts were
supposed to take later this year on
their way to circle the moon but in
Houston NASA has a problem we are facing
challenges both uh
technical uh and just dealing with going
back to the Moon Artemis is the name of
the missions to the moon and the
upcoming launch has been pushed back
from November of this year until
September 2025 I was a bit surprised how
much later it was going to be about a
10mon uh uh push back when there is
liftoff it will almost certainly make
history the 10-day Mission around the
moon will potentially go farther into
space than any human has ever traveled
but but NASA is facing multiple issues
to make that happen life support
hardware and electrical systems that
allow the crew to pull away from the
capsule in case of emergency both failed
in testing that's on top of battery
issues in the Orion spacecraft which the
crew will fly around the moon in the
NASA people kept saying safety safety
safety is because these really are all
safety things and yeah NASA has it in
their mandate to do really cool science
and space things and not kill anybody in
the person I think I'm definitely
disappointed that cool science aided by
Canadian geologist Gordon ozinsky who's
been training the crew on what they
could find on The Far Side of the Moon a
place humans have never gone we're going
to a part of the Moon that we don't see
from the earth and so it's kind of
tucked around on the lower part of the
Moon the South polar region the man dub
Dr crer is hoping moon rocks and water
can be brought back for further analysis
I'll be participating in ous three when
the first humans step back on the
surface of the Moon is really exciting
and if I have to wait another year for
that then you know so be it if the
Artemis 3 mission to land on the Moon is
successful in late 2026 it will be the
first time since 1972 Donna that humans
have been on the moon I remember that of
course McKenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
still ahead Earth records its hottest
year
ever
investigators are trying to figure out
what reduced part of this hotel in Fort
Worth Texas to Rubble an explosion
Monday injured at least 21 people and
Scattered debris onto the streets
authorities suspect a gas leak is to
blame but are still searching for
evidence well it's not a surprise yet it
is deeply troubling it is now confirmed
2023 was the hottest year in recorded
history and likely the hottest in
100,000 years records were Shattered by
significant amounts data from the
Cernic's climate change service shows
every day of 2023 was at least 1° C
above pre-industrial temperatures and
for nearly half those days Global daily
temperatures exceeded
1.5° the elnino weather cycle was a
factor but only a small one and as
Redmond Shannon reports climate
scientists warn the burning of fossil
fuels will keep driving temperatures
up last year's 6500 wildfires across
Canada burned a total area more than
three times that of Nova Scotia a
staggering record breaking year of fires
much of them and many other extreme
weather events fueled by the planet's
hottest average temperatures since
records began and likely long before
that there were simply no cities no
books agriculture or domesticated
animals on this planet last time the
temperature was so high the European
Union's cernus Climate Change Report
shows how in the early part of the Year
temperatures were already trending well
above the previous 30-year average but
then from June they were turbocharged
just look at Canada the suddenness of
the spike was partly due to the El Nino
cycle in the Pacific but experts say the
records are mostly the result of human
generated emissions it would be
impossible to explain uh this picking
global temperature without climate
change so climate change has been
definitely a driver the report says the
Earth was 1.48 de C above pre-industrial
levels last year almost at the 1.5
threshold of the Paris climate agreement
although that would only be breached by
temperatures across a 20year average the
report also contains a list of
Staggering statistics just look at how
the decades have gotten warmer and then
look at
2023 it was the first time on record
that every day within a year had
exceeded one degrees above that
pre-industrial average sea ice is at or
close to record lows water temperatures
at record highs this year could be
warmer again scientists say it depends
on El Nino's Peak but putting that aside
it's basically certain that the average
temperature over the next 5 years will
be warmer than the average temperature
over the Last 5 Years Redmond Channel
Global News
London South Korea has passed
legislation Banning the production and
sale of dog meat the bill aims to end a
centuries old practice that's
increasingly unpopular the law will make
slaughtering breeding and sales of dog
meat for human consumption illegal and
punishable by two to three years in
prison the ban will go into effect by
2027 hailed is Heroes next how these
Montreal teenagers turned into
Lifesavers
they were in the right place at the
right time and they jumped into action
two teenagers from Montreal saved a
British couple who were struggling in
the ocean off Barbados Amanda Jello Wiki
reports on the Split Second decision
they made that ended up saving
lives Emma basserman and Zoe mclen
Ireland had just finished Boogie
boarding together in Barbados they were
leaving the beach when they saw a woman
struggling I went out to her and um she
told me that her husband was further out
and he was struggling to swim Emma 14
and Zoe 13 are both experienced swimmers
Emma is with the doorbell swim team
training for Olympic trials Zoe's father
is the coach with no lifeguards around
the girls sprang to action the undertoe
that day was pretty
strong but the woman's husband was
flailing in the water about 150 ft from
Shore they grabbed a boogie board and
without hesitating swam out to help he
was trying to swim but we could tell
that he was struggling they put him on
the board tied it to Zoe's ankle and
then swam for all their lives it was a
pretty long and tiring so i' say just
because we had to we were also pulling
him too I didn't want to show them that
I was scared because I would make them
even more worried about our safety and
their own with the man safe news spread
quickly about the girl's heroic actions
I'm so proud of both of them and I think
they don't realize how much this means
they've saved you know lives to come in
here it could have been way worse I
think that we both handled it extremely
well and we did what we needed to to
help them the girls have a few more days
of vacation before returning to Montreal
as real life Heroes Amanda jela wikii
Global News
Montreal wow so strong and composed that
is global national for this Tuesday I'm
Donna freezen tonight's your Canada is
the Peace Bridge in Calgary we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers global.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
byebye